Hallo, guten Tag. Guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Atak. Ich bin auf dieser Station als Assistenzarzt tätig.
Ich würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden? Gerne.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Aydin, Mehmet Aydin.
Oh, sind Sie türkisch?
Richtig. Weil ich kann kein Türkisch.
Herr Aydin, könnten Sie Ihren Vornamen langsam bestabieren?
Mein Nachname ist AYDIN.
Und mein Vorname ist MEHMET.
Wie alt sind Sie? Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin 33 Jahre alt. Ich bin am 12. Juli 1992 geboren.
Okay. Wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,75 Meter groß.
Wie viel wiegen Sie zurzeit?
Ich wiege ungefähr 75 Kilogramm.
Okay, danke für diese Informationen.
Herr Aydin, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Weil ich heute jeweils starke Bauchschmerzen habe.
Ich habe Angst, dass ich etwas Schlimmes haben könnte.
Die Schmerzen gehen auch nicht weg.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Ich habe die Schmerzen seit ungefähr einem Tag.
Aber die werden jetzt schlimmer.
Die haben gestern Nachmittag angefangen.
Okay, Nachmittag.
Könnten Sie die Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Sind die drücken?
Das sind stechende, drückende Schmerzen.
Die sind im Mittelbauch.
Sie strahlen aber auch in den rechten Unterbauch.
Strahlen? Wo hinaus?
Im rechten Unterbauch.
Aber sind diese Schmerzen im Mittelbauch angefangen?
Richtig, genau.
Wie stark sind diese Schmerzen auf einer Schmerzkala von 1 bis 10 vorbei?
10 unerträglich?
Mittlerweile bei ungefähr 6.
Sind diese Schmerzen dauerhaft oder gehen sie wieder weg?
Die sind dauerhaft.
Könnten Sie diese Schmerzen bis zum Ende des Gesprächs aushalten?
Möchten Sie Medikamente erhalten?
Ich denke, ich kann das noch aushalten.
Okay, gut.
Gibt es etwas, was die Schmerzen verstärkt oder lindert?
Ich habe Ibuprofen genommen, das hilft.
Kennen Sie Dosierung von Ibuprofen?
400 mg.
Können Sie begleitende Symptome wie Erbrechen oder Übelkeit?
Übelkeit habe ich auch, aber ich habe mich noch nicht erbrochen.
Oder haben Sie beim Stuhlgang Probleme?
Nein, ein bisschen Durchfall aktuell, aber nicht viel.
Durchfall.
Wie oft gehen Sie auf die Toilette?
Einmal am Tag.
Einmal, okay.
Haben Sie ähnliche Beschwerde früher gehabt?
Das erste Mal.
Haben Sie Fieber, Herr Aydin?
Nein, nein.
Oder haben Sie Stelfrost, Nachschweiß?
Nein.
Hatten Sie einen Unfall oder eine Verletzung?
Haben Sie an Ihrer Haut Farbeveränderungen bemerkt?
Nein, auch nicht.
Haben Sie Atemnot?
Dochüsten?
Auch nicht.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Nein, auch nicht.
Neiden Sie unter Herzrasen, Herzkulaufen?
Nein.
Sind diese Schmerzen gestern plötzlich oder langsam begonnen?
Nein, die haben plötzlich begonnen.
Herr Aydin, haben Sie in letzter Zeit ungewöhn ab- oder zugenommen?
Nein.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Normalerweise ja.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Ein bisschen weniger Appetit aktuell.
Leiden Sie an irgendwelchen chronischen Erkrankungen?
Nein.
Oder wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ich war noch nie im Krankenhaus, nein.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf Medikamente ein?
Ja, Ibuprofen habe ich ja gesagt.
Außer Ibuprofen?
Nein.
Sind bei Ihnen Allergien oder Unverträglichkeiten bekannt?
Ich habe eine Hausstauallergie und eine Katzenallergie.
Wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Mit Gaumenjucken niesen.
Unverträglichkeiten?
Nein, nicht das Wissen.
Okay, super.
Rauchen Sie, Herr Aydin?
Ich rauche nicht, nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Alkohol zu sich?
Gar nicht.
Sie sind sehr jung, ein gesunder Mann.
Ja.
Nehmen Sie bitte nächste Fragen.
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Konsumieren Sie Drogen?
Nein, aktuell nicht.
Okay, super.
Gibt es in Ihrer Familie chronische Erkrankungen?
Ja, also meine Eltern haben Bluthochdruck.
Beide Eltern?
Beide Eltern haben Bluthochdruck und meine Mutter hat eine Schilddrüsenunterfunktion.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe zwei Brüder, ja.
Sind Sie gesund?
Die sind gesund.
Sind Sie verheiratet oder?
Nein.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein, auch nicht.
Sind Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland gewesen?
Nein, das war im Sommer gewesen, letztes Jahr.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, ich denke schon.
Treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Ja.
Was machen Sie als Sport?
Als Sport?
Ich laufe, Fitness.
Wie oft machen Sie Sport?
Wie oft?
Zweimal in der Woche.
Was sind Sie für einen Beruf?
Ich bin Programmierer, ITer.
Programmierer.
Ich bin IT.
Ich arbeite in der IT.
Programmierer ist ein Beruf?
Ja, ich arbeite in der IT.
Softwareprogrammierer.
Programmierer.
Programmieren.
Okay.
Haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit oder im Privatleben?
Eigentlich nicht, nein.
Ist alles gut.
Ja.
Herr Aydin, meine wichtige Fragen.
Ich habe meine wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Möchten Sie noch etwas hinzufügen?
Oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Haben Sie schon eine Bedachtstiagnose,
was ich haben könnte, eventuell?
Ja, ich habe eine Vermutung.
Aber es ist noch zu früh um etwas ...
... genauso zu machen.
Genau so sagen.
Zu früh etwas genauso sagen.
Deswegen würde ich zunächst bei Ihnen
die Vitalparameter kontrollieren
und eine körperliche Untersuchung durchführen.
Aber zunächst würde ich beeilen,
dass Sie sich nicht mehr bewegen.
Ich würde Blut abnehmen
und eine Bauchultraschall durchführen
und einige Untersuchungen veranlassen.
Sobald ich alle Ergebnisse erhalten habe,
werde ich weitere Informationen mitteilen.
Ich habe eine Frage vergessen.
Haben Sie Probleme mit Masalasen?
Nein, ich habe keine Probleme mit Masalasen.
Vielen Dank.
Haben Sie Kollegen oder Kollegen
noch andere Fragen?
Herr Aydin, Sie haben schon gesagt,
dass Sie Durchfall haben.
Wie oft gehen Sie zur Toilette?
Und wie ist die Konsistenz?
Einmal, einmal.
Und schleimig.
Und haben Sie Schmerzen beim Stuhlgang?
Nein, nein.
Das ist auch seit gestern nur einmal gewesen.
Nachdem ich die Schmerzen habe.
Und haben Sie Blut im Stuhl bemerkt?
Nein, habe ich nicht bemerkt.
Danke.
Herr Aydin, ich habe eine Frage.
Sind Ihre Schmerzen,
Sie haben Bauch,
wie gesagt Mittelbauch,
Oberbauch oder Unterbauch?
Ich habe gesagt Mittelbauch,
aber in den rechten Unterbauch ziehen.
Ich habe auch eine Frage.
Bevor die Schmerzen,
waren Sie schwindelig
oder hatten Sie
Inappetenz?
Nein.
Inappetenz habe ich jetzt seitdem ich Schmerzen habe.
Also habe ich wenig Appetit.
Also ich habe die Schmerzen seit gestern Nachmittag.
Ja.
Im Mittelbauch.
Und in den rechten Unterbauch ziehen.
Darf ich?
Wie bitte?
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Haben wir gerade beantwortet, nein.
Ist Ihnen ein harter Bauch
aufgefallen?
Ein harter Bauch?
Ja.
Nein.
Der ist weich, aber wenn ich drauf drücke, tut das weh.
Okay, gibt keine weiteren Fragen.
Sollen wir das Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch beginnen?
Ja.
Ja?
Ich kann probieren.
Guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Guten Tag.
Ich habe heute einen neuen
Patient
aufgenommen
und möchte
ihn Ihnen vorstellen.
Hätten Sie kurz Zeit für mich?
Danke Herr Oberarzt.
Unser Patient heißt
Mehmet Aydin.
Herr Aydin ist
33 Jahre alt,
1,75 Meter
groß und
75 Kilogramm schwer.
Der Patient
stellt sich heute
wegen
seit einem Tag
bestehende
Druckende
persistierende
Bauchschmerzen
in der Mitte
mit
Austrahlung
in den
rechten Unterbauch
bei uns vor.
Die Schmerzintensität
wurde von den
Patienten
mit 6 von 10
auf der Schmerzskala bewertet.
Der Patient berichtete,
dass die Schmerzen
plötzlich
begonnen haben.
Im Laufe der Zeit
hat der Patient
über 500
Milligramm
eingenommen
und diese Medikamente
hat ihm
Linderung gebracht.
Außerdem klagte der Patient
über
Übelkeit,
Nausea ohne Enesis.
Die Fragen nach
Fieber,
Verletzung, Unfall,
Hautfarbeveränderungen
und den Paralyn.
Die Vegetative-Anhemnese
ist unauffällig
bis auf
Schmerze bedingte
Inapetens.
Bei ihm
sind
Vorerkrankungen und
Voroperationen
nicht
bekannt
oder
bei ihm
nicht bekannt.
Besuch nicht der Medikation
nimmt der Patient
über Profan
500 Milligramm bei Bedarf ein.
Der Patient hat
Hauszutau
und Katzenhaare
Allergien,
die sich durch
Pyruritis und
Renitis ausernt.
Der Patient hat
Hauszutau
und Katzenhaare Allergien,
die sich durch
Pyruritis
und Renitis ausernt.
Herr Aydin hat
keine Unfälle.
Der Nikotinkonsum,
der Nikotin,
Alkohol
und Drogenkonsum
wurden verneint.
Sein Vater
leidet an Arterielle Hypertonie.
Seine Mutter leidet an
Arterielle Hypertonie.
Arterielle Hypertonie
und an Hypothriose.
Er hat zwei
gesunde
Brüder.
Er ist ledig
und
arbeitet
bei der
IT Firma
als
Programmierer.
Die Reiseanemnese
ist unaufwendig.
Der Impfstatus ist aktuell.
Er läuft
zweimal pro Woche.
Er hat
keinen Stress
bei der Arbeit
oder im Privatleben.
Die anämnistischen Angaben
deuten am besten
auf eine akute
Appenditis hin.
Da der Patient
typische Symptome
aufweist,
zum Beispiel
plötzlich
begonnen
und Schmerzlokalisation
und Überkeit,
Schmerzintensität.
Als die finanziellen Diagnosen
kommen,
kommen
eine
Divertikulitis
oder chronische
entzündliche
Darmerkrankung
wie
Colitis usulosa
oder
Morbus Crohn
in Betracht.
Um meine Verdachtdiagnose zu bestätigen,
würde ich
beiden Patienten
zunächst
die Vitalparameter kontrollieren
und eine körperliche Untersuchung
durchführen.
Bei der körperlichen Untersuchung
achte ich darauf,
ob
Druckdolenz, Aufwechspannung,
Loslassschmerz,
Organomegalie
vorliegen.
Bei diesem Fall
ist
McBurnay-Zychen
wichtig.
Sehr wichtig.
Natürlich
würde ich nach der
körperlichen
Untersuchung
eine
Abdomenzonographie
durchführen
und mögliche andere
Pathologien
ausschließen.
Und gegebenenfalls würde ich
eine Computer-
tomographische Abdomenz
durchführen.
Dann
würde ich eine
chirurgische Konzilanfordern
um die Therapie
des Patienten
zu optimieren.
Was? Bestimmen Sie
Blut? Ja.
Und dann
würde ich eine
Laboon-Testung durchführen
und Blut mit
Entzündungsparameter, CRP, BSG,
Leberwerte,
Nierenwerte,
Prokacitonin.
Und ich habe vergessen, außerdem
können wir als
Differentialdiagnosen
eine
Theolinophritis
denken. Deswegen
würde ich eine
Üringtest bestimmen lassen.
Also am Anfang immer Labor, Urin,
sowas in der Art.
Und danach kommen erst
CT
und Chirurgie zu tun.
Die Reihenfolge war ein bisschen verkehrt.
Ja, richtig.
Ein bisschen vermischt.
Sollte sich meine Verdachtstdiagnose
bestätigen, würde ich
den Patienten
stationär
aufnehmen und einen
Behandlungsdienst machen.
Dabei würde ich eine Anarchie
Anti-Ammetika
Ampirische Antibiotika
verabreichen.
Weiter in der Terapeutik
werden wir die
Ergebnisse
nein,
würde ich
den Ergebnisse der
Untersuchungen
anpassen.
Sehr gut.
Ich habe noch eine Frage.
Was ein Erschütterungsschmerz ist.
Erschütterungsschmerz.
Kennen Sie das?
Bei einer akuten
Appendizitis
kann man Untersuchungen machen.
Man kann einen sogenannten
Erschütterungsschmerz
provozieren.
Man kann den Patienten
sagen, stehen Sie
bitte auf und springen Sie ein wenig.
Ja, gibt es eine verschiedene...
Wenn der Patient dann sagt,
ja, ich habe Schmerzen
auf der rechten Seite,
rechten Unterbau, dann können Sie schon
sicher sein, dass es wahrscheinlich
eine Appendizitis ist.
Es gibt eine verschiedene
körperliche Untersuchungen.
Zum Beispiel eine
Dynamo, erinnere mich
nicht, aber
Pussolaz-Zeichen.
Genau.
Diese Sachen sollten Sie vielleicht
auch erwähnen.
Wenn Sie den Patienten körperlich
untersuchen, sollten Sie das auch
aufführen, was Sie genau machen.
Neckburn, Erschütterungsschmerz,
zum Beispiel
Contralatalala,
Loserschmerz.
Ist nicht immer vorhanden, kann aber
vorhanden sein.
Zum Beispiel.
Vielen Dank. Super.
Ja, sehr gut.
Ich denke, das ist alles richtig,
was Sie gesagt haben.
Ja, ich bedanke mich bei Ihnen
für diese angenehme Gespräche.
Gut, nächste Frage, oder haben andere
noch Fragen?
Darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Ja.
Haben Sie gesagt,
ich habe eine schleime Stuhlgang?
Ist das richtig oder nicht?
Ja, schleimige Stuhlgang.
Ist das besüchtigt mit Appendicitis?
Nein.
Danke schön.
Manchmal hat man auch gar keinen Durchfall.
Meistens hat man keinen Durchfall.
Ich habe eine Frage, Herr Ogras.
Was können wir
aus differenzierter Diagnose
bei diesem Fall sagen?
Also bei diesem Fall kann man letztendlich sagen,
dass es eine Divertikulitis
auch kontralateral sein könnte.
Sie haben richtig gesagt,
es könnte eine Pyronephritis sein.
Es könnte eine ganz normale
Gastroenteritis sein.
Eine Beginnende zum Beispiel.
Was könnte es sein zum Beispiel?
Ja, danke.
Und genau.
So was in der Art.
Genau.
Die Kollegen oder der Kollege hat schon
was aufgeschrieben.
Sie haben CED,
chronischen entzündliche Darmerkrankungen.
Bei Damen auch.
Vielleicht eine Ovarialzyste.
Das kann auch sein.
Es gibt viele Diagnosen.
Schwangerschaft kann sein.
Bei Frauen,
nicht bei Männern.
Gibt es noch Fragen?
Es gibt viele
klinische Zeichen
für die akute Appendicitis.
Aber manchmal
könnte man sagen,
falschen Begriff.
Mark-Burnay-Zeichen
oder Punkt.
Wie kann man beschreiben
diese klinischen Zeichen?
Also man sagt in der Regel
Mark-Burnay-Punkt.
Ohne Zeichen.
Ist das nicht?
Ja, Mark-Burnay-Punkt.
Schmerz oder Mark-Burnay-Punkt.
Spina, Iliaka und Bauchnabel.
Anterior-Superior.
Genau.
Zwischen Spina, Iliaka,
Anterior-Superior und Bauchnabel.
Aber außer...
Das ist die Mono-Linie.
Und dann gibt es den
zwei Drittel.
An der rechten Seite.
Wenn man diese Punkte
durchschmert,
gibt es
einen
oder
wenn wir
besagnen.
Ja, durchschmert.